[Music]
in love at first sight news submitted by
maja and mihaela we didn't have that
mihaela Mahina a woman a woman fell in
love with an alcoholic homeless man she
met on the screen damn that fool came up
hard no what does she look like though
initiative how she know he was alcoholic
maybe she's an alcoholic really fit
homeless people that should be so funny
she's like I fell in love with the
alcohol was better you take it though
she was like Ewing oh you didn't yeah he
takes it pretty sure he was just
homeless that she just added all the
[ __ ] to him he added an affectation so
that it was like I need to save him
exactly I was about to say did you show
me how crazy women are I can change man
oh I got a got a broken arm well cuz if
there's a reason to blame the
homelessness I can fix it but if it's
just like you out there on your own
sober I bet you this - I bet you he
wasn't even homeless he was just sitting
on a curb eating a burrito
he's a hipster that's it oh yeah oh my
god let me save you from what [ __ ] I
was eating a burrito from yourself
especially with the style now you guys
know the style is everything's ripped up
like homeless rag clothes I know I like
it cuz then it's like you just have
ripped up clothes and like you'll have
to go shopping like what's his name
Shila bois food for you he always wears
like the military reserve you know
ration clothes or whatever that's a kiss
[ __ ] I saw I can't shirt look
interesting yeah
so this story is about Emmy and Vic and
they met back in 2006 and and Amsterdam
when Vic so at that time loved Amsterdam
by the way yeah beautiful
I love Amsterdam - it's [ __ ] here I
love the pictures it's [ __ ] amazing I
don't remember seeing any a homeless
panini there's no they have like
socialism and like government takes care
of homes
I remember seeing them either you're
right a lot of cats though a lot of cats
on the street I just think it's full of
stoners hookers and guys with wooden
shoes but they all have homes that
culture is wooden shoes the windmills
and you an American Vic is an American
and at that time he was doing like a
backpacking trip through Europe but then
he ran out of money sooner than he
expected it so he decided like you know
I'd [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna just be homeless
well I cuz he says that he didn't get to
do everything he wanted to do in Europe
so that's why he didn't decide to go
back home so he wasn't homeless though
look in that country and he lets see the
outlaws and where it comes in he just
had one beer it was a kombucha when Amy
met him she says that he was carrying
around a suitcase with him which she
thought was really weird but then later
on she found out that that's why he
would keep his sleeping bag and he would
also keep cans of beer in theirs because
he was a heavy drinker and so he says
that after they met that's when he
realized like oh my gosh I'm actually
into a holic homeless at this point um
was he addicted to drinking because I
feel like sometimes that's a survival
mechanism like ice to not be able to
afford groceries but I would get a
six-pack of beer and that would be
dinner like the one one beer and I it
would be dinner I just put it like this
this just goes to show that he was happy
before he met her
you're then it always takes a woman to
point out your flaws he didn't know he
was alcoholic he would just have some
bad beer does it you mean make him
better yeah no no you mean make him
better she immediately knew that he was
there she that he was you know
struggling yeah dirty clothes and dirty
hair
but she was struck by his beautiful
brown eyes so he approached her and
apparently it seems like he was
panhandling so then that's when they met
and then so they ended up talking they
talked for about 10 minutes sometime -
it ready and go no I say shoe yes then
they agreed to meet again at the same
bench later a week later first you see
where all the pigeons been [ __ ] from
each ear again and then Amira turned to
Vienna because that's where she
originally is from Vienna sausages okay
then she feared that she would never see
Vick again so holes may be dead before
they pointed before they parted ways she
gave him they do one of these when they
left like the the date he couldn't have
paid for anything so basically they just
have really good sex and she was like
damn I'm never gonna find dick like that
back home how am I gonna find this dude
again yeah yeah cuz there's no way he
would pay for something less that's what
happened but yeah so then it smell it
smells like fur angular dick is bad
enough as it is
homeless dick though oh sure no wash no
nothing so they were very excited uh
saving up money as much as he could to
go see her in Vienna and so finally he
was able to afford to go see her and he
called her up and then we met and then
like more than a decade later they have
kids to see little kid they're married
and they have twins
they live in a V&O what good for you -
all these side conversations you still
got to try to like know you notice how I
didn't interrupt thank you so much I
definitely did interrupt you but I was
thinking about how what could make me
want to give my number to a homeless man
unless it was some good dick better days
I mean she's saying like instantly they
had chemistry and like they just started
talking
I'm a bit disappointed that the the
children don't look like Lord of the
Flies like straight up like island
children that's wearing like a ragtag
you thought that she was gonna convert
to his life I I was hoping that she
would liberate herself from the shackles
of the normal normal 905 so what does he
do now he doesn't drink electrical
engineer damn you need a degree for that
[ __ ] yeah he transformed his life by
doing that that's nice I even got
married in a castle oh we're all the
ghosts he was a part-time homeless like
a vacation
woman this was by choice almost oh so
that's a pretty crazy story I can't
choose to be I can't do that [ __ ] I need
me a bed you got homeless on vacation
that's just bad planning he's a good guy
and like those hostels are pretty cheap
like he probably had a bed at night you
think maybe my keys are cutting down his
home even if he Panhandle ten dollars he
could afford though they're saying that
he lived in a bush what that is [ __ ]
hilarious hopefully it wasn't during the
winter months of Amsterdam I just feel
like the holes outside it's like excuse
me you could just sleep in this hostel
yeah I got me a bush out here I'm
American I sleep in [ __ ] okay he just
needed a good story I understand that
they told their gym their love story
like how they met and that it seems like
the kids don't fully grasp the whole
situation because they're just thinking
that it's funny that Daddy lived in a
bush everybody funny that your daddy
lived in a bush cuz I've never been a
single homeless person that lived in a
bush you know I'm saying like that's not
the choice before in the bush cuz I did
that when I was a kid before I like cut
the inner branches out I made like a
look you haven't got all uncomfortable
it is to live in a bush that shit's
pokey a schmuck
well like behind the behind the freeway
thing
[Music]
hence like I've seen people live then
you live in a tent
very odd choice for this man so
basically there's no changes
oh my god those [ __ ] Bush spy boys
spiders I that dude came up hard yeah
man this reminds me of like um so when I
was bored I used to I used to read
Craigslist's mist encounter section have
you ever it's so [ __ ] interesting I
don't know I haven't been on it in ages
but then it reminds me of something like
that where it's like oh you we were at
the concert we looked at each other I
want I wanted to say something and I'm
like damn I wonder if they ever got
together yeah encounters yeah or
something it was like misconnections or
something yeah I forgot but it was it
was pretty interesting like does then
you wouldn't know a blonde
five-foot-five who was at the like
Stevie Ray concert or whatever yeah it
was like you were wearing a purple
sweater yeah I was wearing this like
sometimes they get really hot actually
yeah I see you I want to meet a couple
that goes Nesta I have yet to meet a
couple that had that moment you know me
where they saw each other across the
room and [ __ ] like a movie
yes sparks flew they moved to another
place and somehow they met up somewhere
else I need to see that she didn't
realize because I want to believe in
that type of love yeah Casey says when
he first saw me like he saw that he was
like I saw you from across the bar and
he was just like illuminating in my like
shot what did you see
I didn't be in that you saw slant-eyed
[ __ ] huh she saw him with a straw hat
in a [ __ ] in a pitchfork in [ __ ] you
saw this ball just cleaning rice out of
a basket he the first time I saw him but
he didn't I don't think you even
remembered me yeah we were at a premiere
for this movie that I was in briefly
like a small role and his girlfriend was
in also and then our mutual friend
director like was part of the production
team and so I met him as the girl's
boyfriend right but he the way he
treated her like
they were dancing to this Juke jukebox
and he was like spinning her and he was
really funny and I just like I was like
I want a guy like that and I had a
boyfriend at the time no no you said I
want that guy I did that was later that
was five years later I wrote that down
in a journal well good for you for not
stealing Steve away and being oh no I
would never be a homewrecker that's good
yeah and he would never be a cheater so
like he was crossed off the list when I
met him but I was like that's out there
hmm
because you got like there guys like
that exist yeah like that's like just a
some movie it's a movie character it's
not so Muriel had this perception of a
man that she wanted right yeah and I
took my hammer and I shattered that [ __ ]
and I said this is what's real do you
understand this man that you created in
your head does not [ __ ] exist I had a
dream and a wish and I prayed to the
fairy godmother
please give me a beautiful girl with a
luscious but that's very intelligent and
then the fairy godmother gave me that
gift and you're like and be careful what
you wish for
yeah I wasn't specific enough but it was
like you're like give me one that I can
yell at all the time yeah but the but
then she has dogs and that's a plus well
maybe they like a piece of crap I'll
tell you this I know you didn't see what
[ __ ]
[Music]